- So D-Rock, I want to
make some Gary V originals,
you know, these videos that we do ad-hoc,
not the Ask Gary V
Shows, not the Keynotes,
and today I want to make a video
about what just happened.
(car horn honking)
Oh, I love you New York.
What just happened?
Here's what happened.
I'm on jury duties, duties, duty.
My entire calendar is cleared, right?
They give us a very long lunch.
What do I do?
I don't sit and chill it out.
I don't sit and say, "Well I
don't have anything scheduled."
I email the team, we bang out Episode 114
of the Ask Gary V Show.
I email Matt, my assistant,
he's hanging out over there.
Looks kind of creepy.
Looks super suspicious.
Anyway, anyway, Matt's here,
so we're gonna go through a bunch of stuff
that we have to execute against.
I have two calls right
after I do this video.
Phil Toronto from Vayner/RSE, the fund,
is coming and having a meeting
that was gonna be at 11:30 p.m. tonight,
he's coming to meet me at one.
Basically, what I'm fascinated by,
is that people like to say they hustle,
and I talk about working the whole day.
And then I've talked to guys a lot about,
well, it's not about how much you sleep,
it's what you do while you're awake.
And this is a perfect example of something
that I've watched a lot
of my contemporaries
and a lot of you, the
Vayner Nation, right?
That say they love to hustle,
when something happens, a
meeting gets canceled, right?
There's a curveball,
it's a snow day, right?
They take that as vacation time
instead of adjusting to it.
See, the truth of the matter is
being efficient, executing,
shooting for those big goals
is predicated on your actions.
Do you take a extra long
lunch from jury duty
to say you know what,
cool, I'm gonna chill
and watch YouTube videos,
or do you hustle your face off
and try to cram as much in?
You know, I'm excited that
that's my first thought.
Now look, I get it, I'm
sitting on a high chair
right now, and talking down to,
like you should do this.
I'm really not, I'm really not,
I'm really not telling
you what you should do.
I'm really not trying to be a guru.
I'm not really trying to be too cool
and say hahaha, look at me, not you.
I'm really, really, really not.
I'm really just making these videos,
not for the people that,
you find this condescending.
Not for the few people
that find it motivational.
I'm making this video for the people
that are full of sh, right?
The ones that tell me to my
face every day that yeah...
And really want it, and
don't recognize the actions
that it takes to get there,
so I'm making this video for a very small
percentage of you.
To the left, look, Gary
thinks he's so cool,
to the right, that's the best ever,
complete blindness, no, the middle.
The middle my friends.
So many of you that actually want this,
have the skills to do this, right?
And sometimes, once in a while,
just need to see a different version of it
to understand, ahh, right?
Ahh.
To me this is an ahh video, right?
Did you mail it in?
Did you mail in that 15 minute,
15 minute call got canceled,
you had a packed day, 15 hour day,
it got canceled, what are
you doing in that 15 minutes?
And, by the way,
sometimes those 15 minutes
are absolutely worth calling your mom,
calling your daughter,
FaceTime with your kids.
But it's just making every minute count,
every minute has to count.
Every minute has to count
if you want so much because you just don't
have as many of them as you think.
You just don't.